after the setup about Chris and his new
job it says show that P which is the
value of the investment after 240 months
just P on its own show that it is and
then there's this dollar figure right so
you need to get to this there are is it
three no it's two marks on this right so
when they say show the emphasis is on
you to be able to demonstrate I know
where everything has come from which is
why you must start like this let me say
it again okay if you want to establish
something about an nth term or a two
hundred and fortieth term you have to be
able to get the first the second the
third that's your foundation okay
many times people have come to me
they've said I've got an answer it's not
it's not quite right
it's almost always the problem is not
like down here the problem is up here
either this doesn't exist so you just
form the wrong series or for example
when you were reading the question you
read monthly or annually wrong with
something like that so it was in the
establishment of the series that you
fell down okay so P 1 P 2 P 3 do not
take shortcuts around it because it's
not a shortcut because then you get the
question wrong and then you're like wait
what happened you're trying to work it
out okay so you form your series once
you've got your first three then in this
context you can go straight to the 240th
having established this part here okay
now I keep on pointing out this and I'm
really happy I've seen lots of you
following this convention I encourage
you to do it because it shows that you
understand what the GP is it's also
worth mentioning at this point I'll just
put your pens down from it because this
one's a this is a tricky thing to note I
said I started off with a superannuation
question like this when we did these
applications and then later on I moved
to a loan repayment one of the reasons
why loan repayments are generally viewed
as harder is because here everything
you've gotten here is the GP right but a
loan repayment will have an extra bit
it'll actually have the loan that you're
repaying so for instance I think we had
some kind of loan like this before it's
like $300,000 and it's getting its own
interest for you know whatever a period
of time that you're in there for and
then it's this take away and then here
are your repayments that are gradually
trying to over
this right now this part here would not
be part of the series and a few of you
when you go to this next part which I'm
going to ask you to help me work out in
a second you forget that there's
actually the loan itself that you're
trying to repay and then your series of
repayments okay so that's another thing
to watch out for now can you help me
write down what is you should all have
this line of working after you identify
the Jaypee what comes next what's the
formula yeah okay so here's my a in this
case here is my R in this case what's my
in 240 take away one what's on the
denominator yeah it's it's R minus 1
again I'm going to encourage you to
actually write R minus 1 one point zero
zero five minus one now this is the GP
part right but I'm missing something
aren't I have a look yeah I factorized
this out so therefore the whole series
has been multiplied by this so there's a
500 right here okay at that point your
calculator can take over we don't expect
you to do any kind of simplify there
especially be that we've already given
you the number okay so now have a look
at part two with me and I want you to
help me do this from the beginning
so part two let's read after retirement
Chris Smith draws $2,000 from the
account at the end of each month without
making any further deposits so this is
kind of like it's kind of like a loan
repayment in that money keeps coming out
it's just a different kind of situation
but you'll find the equations that we
form are more or less identical to a
loan repayment the account continues to
earn interest at the same 0.5 percent
per month that I had before okay
and by the way this is exactly how super
works like you put lots of money in and
then at such time as your income no
longer continues you can sort of draw on
it and the fact that it's so large means
that the interest that you get is still
reasonable and you just try not to take
it out too fast
okay let a of n be the amount left in
the account n months after retirement so
pause they're a whole new situation has
begun right so we're going to do
somewhat
get that this 240 months has happened
this is going to be a new starting point
show that a event equals that it up and
there are three marks on this okay you
can see the way that we started this
question what's going to be the very
first thing that you write down for part
2 a 1 thank you okay
we're establishing a pattern just like
we did before can someone tell me what
is the expression for a 1 what do we
begin with this is one month right well
you start with this figure like that was
what was in there at the end of all of
his saving right so I'm just going to
call this P because I already have a a
pruning rule attached to it I could call
it P 240 that would fall into the
convention but they literally said in
the question that just capital P on its
own is that amount okay and there's
nothing wrong with writing this number
I'm just lazy to write it and I've
already got a letter associated with it
what happens to it does it owe any
interest first or does he take out the
$2,000 first read carefully have a look
have a look the account now just read
the question I'm not gonna answer this
question for you you can read it
yourself we've done quite a few of these
look at the question and tell me what do
you think happens first
well you reckon jacent interest one
point zero zero five what is the key
phrase that jason has identified that
tells us interest is first at the at the
end of each month that's when the
withdrawal happens takeaway mm is that
okay so read the question carefully you
always see a clue kind of like that in
there so that's that figure there should
I go ahead and work out what this actual
number is I can find out what it is like
I can evaluate it why not
why isn't there some advantage to it
like wouldn't it be simpler to just get
a number say it again area number one it
doesn't ask us to evaluate this but
number two it does not help right cuz
why did I do P one in the first place
why do a one so why did I write this
down I'm trying to establish a pattern
right so therefore keeping it in this
form is actually better off for me now I
can form a two off the back of this
right two things happen every time there
is the interest and then there's the
withdrawal right so we could write this
down we can go here's the interest
that's two zeros and there he's a
withdrawal are you happy with that
starting to form the series how many
more do I need just the one more and
this is what I was trying to mention
before in that if you didn't know any
better and you were just looking at this
working without the context of the
question does this not look exactly like
a loan repayment situation where here is
your loan here's the prince we're trying
to pay off and here are the repayments
the difference is I he's actually taking
this money out it's for him as opposed
to giving it to a bank okay would you
like to do anything to this before we
generalize you don't have to but you can
what which would you prefer to do are
you generally a you see how see how this
is factorized out I could have actually
factorize one more time are you
generally factorizing out or are you
just going from there who factorizes
hands up
a couple of you here smiling about a 30
B okay here Sam why don't we do it just
because I had it factorized over here we
can do it here it's not complicated I've
got one point zero zero five cubed what
factor would you like me to remove - mm
are you happy with that what's that
going to leave me with while I'm at it I
might as well reorder this thing because
I like to write things in descending
order it's just easier for my brain to
process I'm gonna have a single lot of -
mm over there then what comes next I'm
gonna add because I've taken out that
minus sign
come on Michael help me out what's the
next term very good and then because
this is the third one thinner ax what's
gonna finish off this series I've got
this term I've got this term what's left
cool well then here we go now I'm ready
to generalize this thing okay now just
come back to the question it says show
that a of N equals so I want to go dot
dot dot a of N and I'm gonna have the
whole series and then I'm gonna collapse
it down to get to the expression okay so
I've got this guy out the front
how many lots of interest should it have
match up the numbers have a look it's
gonna have n lots of interest applied to
it right take away mm here all of his
withdrawals and it's not just the same
way that we had in the previous line but
where does it end what is the final term
one point zero zero five to what power
yeah look you can see how this one is
always one less than this number this
number so n minus one there you go okay
that guy there let's switch color that's
the GP and it looks pretty familiar
right so this is a GP with I've gone
with a equals one in this case I know
what my ratio is and how many terms are
there there are n terms just like they
were three here there were two here
there are n terms
yeah okay so now I'm gonna pause for a
minute what do we do next well I'm gonna
launch straight into here okay but this
is going to have like a weird awkward
fraction in it as this sum of GP always
does does the result that we want have a
weird awkward fraction in it no so what
are we gonna have to do after we get to
this line what all we need to do you've
seen this before right
what comes next hey is that the front -
mm because that's just factorized out
okay can you tell me what the weird or
contraction is rear can you see it
perfect okay now all you usually get to
what we want to end up with is see how
you've got this one point zero zero five
to the end here I shall just highlight
that for you you've got it over here you
also have one sort of nestled in here
right but all of this is just a bit of
rearrangement to get to the actual line
that they want are you happy with that
do you need me to write it down I think
I think you're okay with it because
you're only one or two lines off you're
gonna use your calculator a little bit
because you can see they've got P in
there as well but that - 400,000 is
going to come from here once that all
gets on the wash okay so we're done
you'll get your final line as required